on and you're good
for me digital marketing and racing are
close to my heart while one is my
profession
they're both my passions I'm happy I've
created a place for myself in
Motorsports and carved a niche in the
marketing world even before I completed
the course I was hired by a startup
agency within nearly 70 percent increase
in my hourly rate hi I'm Ivy boyder I
live in Florida with my family and have
over 20 years worth experience but my
journey with marketing began almost 11
years ago when I started a family and
lifestyle blog it soon became a source
of income for me and digging into the
data became not only a passion but my
profession
after learning many aspects of marketing
through my blogging journey I became a
marketing manager for a local
Motorsports Park where I worked in
social media and SEO there I was able to
combine my hobby with my marketing
experience which was really exciting for
me later I found it difficult to get
started as an SEO professional in an
agency setting but knew I wanted to
specialize in SEO so I decided to take
the advanced SEO certification course
from Simply learn the certification came
with a lot of benefits including the
flexibility to consume content at my own
pace and allowed me to test when I was
ready I learned about keyword research
on and off page optimization and
Technical aspects of SEO after that I
was promoted to SEO manager overseeing a
small team where I saw an additional
increase in my salary
I'm glad I get to utilize my skills in
digital marketing while staying home and
spending time with my family however I
still do need to get out and spend time
with my husband participating in our
usual racing activities I got started in
on across about 10 years ago served as
the treasurer for our local scca group
and continue to participate in autocross
track events and rally cross my next
goal is to compete in some rally events
in the US and Motorsports
to set a sustainable pace for constantly
push yourself to learn and
think about it that's probably how we
should approach everything in life